chirurgien de la main à l'hôpital de
trappes christian couturier refuse
d'être pris pour un pigeon en grève
illimitée depuis lundi il a rejoint ce
mercredi ses confrères et consoeurs pour
manifester devant le ministère de la
santé à paris
la cause de cette grogne l'accord sur
les dépassements d'honoraires signé fin
octobre par trois syndicats de médecins
les médecins libéraux dénoncent
l'attitude de la ministre de la santé
marisol touraine à leur égard la plupart
des médecins ont été humiliés par le
comportement et surtout le
ce que le mini la ministre de la santé a
dit parce qu'effectivement on a
l'impression d'avoir été montré du doigt
alors que nous sommes plutôt des gens
vertueux nous travaillons pour soigner
les patients pour leur apporter du
bien-être et si nos tarifs opposables
les tarifs qui est les rembourse n'ont
pas augmenté depuis longtemps mais c'est
pas de notre faute
en secteur 2 le docteur couturier a créé
à l'hôpital de trappes l'un des plus
importants centres soas mains de france
il exerce pour plus de 55 % de son
activité au tarif opposable fixé par la
loi et rappelle qu'une petite centaine
de médecins seulement appliquent un
dépassement d'honoraires au-delà du
raisonnable selon lui l'ordre des
médecins est là pour réguler ces
dérapages
mais il pointe surtout du doigt le
comportement des mutuelles de santé
l'argent de la santé existent et
l'argent de la santé les français l'ont
déjà déboursé faut simplement le trouver
au bon endroit et il est certainement
pas à chez les médecins qui n'ont rien
augmenté depuis des années il est là où
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure sur les
assurances complémentaires qui ne
redistribue pas les 7 milliards d'euros
de bénéfices qu'elles font tous les ans
le docteur couturier a rejoint cet après
midi les deux mille manifestants selon
les organisateurs pour scander sa colère
à ses côtés ses confrères trappistes qui
attendent beaucoup de la manifestation
et souhaite poursuivre le mouvement si
besoin que l'airé discussions soient
prises avec deux représentants c'est à
dire syndicales le bloc qui représente
donc les chirurgiens gynécologues et les
acéistes pour que soient rediscutées
donc les conditions élevé six reprises
sur notamment les compléments
d'honoraires
sont rapides on est une clinique privée
et on est ce qu'on appelle pds mais
c'est à dire qu'on a on a une mission de
service public nuit profonde donc on a
été réquisitionnée moi je ne suis pas
réquisitionner aujourd'hui mais je pense
mon petit doigt me dit que je le serai
demain puisque mes collègues l'ont été
mes deux collègues ont été avant-hier et
hier
maintenant je suis tout à fait disposé
je suis tout à fait prêt à continuer à
ne travailler que sur réquisition un
jour par semaine
voilà c'est pas de problème depuis les
débuts de la semaine 90% du personnel du
secteur chirurgie de l'hôpital de
trappes est en grève